like me and my friends were in sixth
grade with a summer party
and this is kind of [__] rogue
we didn't know what we were doing but we
knew that weed was a thing
but we didn't have access to it or what
the [__] got to get it right went sixth
grade so we rolled up tea
and we rolled up tea and coffee filters
that look like joints yeah we went out
and broke into a golf course that was a
big thing oh yeah you went on the
putting green and just plain stuff
tea and then we people thought they felt
it but nobody felt [__] oh yeah
somebody's all earl greyed up yeah
everybody's [__] chamomile dude
everybody saw that
you said we had this guy named jeff
soviet and he had a gas leak at his
house right but we didn't know so we'd
go over there and sleep for no joke 30
hours do we fall asleep on friday wake
up on [__] sunday right because they
had a um
cmo leak or whatever it is uh carbon
monoxide carbon monoxide so
we get over there dude and like bro you
go through the kitchen his mom would be
like asleep making a [__] salad bro
like we didn't know what was going on i
thought the family was all on drugs on
pills you know whenever inadvertently on
early leads right so then we came out
and uh
and we were all excited about that brown
frown that's what you got in louisiana
it was just [__] gutter bro
somebody [__] grew it in their ass
bro you know and [__] let it ferment
under their nuts bro it was bad
so people would always say yeah i got
some weed but really like you didn't
have any and then you got to like
nighttime people like break out your
[__] weed man so you'd have to get
something fake so of course we got
oregano that's what everybody got like
looked like weed then we'd roll it up
goes out and [__] smoke it
and then come back in and like everybody
would just pretend they were high
because nobody wanted to admit that it
was really weird right nobody wanted to
miss they were just smoking some booty
moths
just rifling up some booty moss bootyma
yeah i know i was trying to explain to
somebody
that we would get weed off the train
tracks
we would go and it would just grow wild
and we would just sit there and pick
leaves and dry them out and it was like
barely a high but we thought we were
[__] full till
we would come back in from pretending we
were out so we now now we're all inside
having to pretend we're high even though
each one of us knows we're not high
right
and we had this one guy between us he
was not the brightest dude brother this
dude named joffrey right
and so first of all if you live in the
south in a simple town don't give your
son
a crazy name okay yeah
because people always will call them
they call them racial slurs all the time
you know
they'd be like oh joffrey that [__]
chick or [__] you know or they throw
something like that out and i'm not
saying those things and my listeners
know that you know
but uh gailing a story yeah and so
anyway yeah we all come back in and
we're like i'm like oh i'm so hungry
dude my buddy's like i can't even
[__] see
right he's just standing on the porch
pretending he can't find his way back
into the house
joffrey doesn't know how to behind he
goes into their kitchen breaks a [__]
mirror with his [__] head oh my god
that's not even a high thing
i know he didn't it was like whoa bro
and it wasn't even weed and that's when
i knew something was [__] wrong with
that dude yeah that's off dude
cause that's back in the day when we i i
don't yeah that's
we just smoked oregano we're like but
we're all like okay
it wasn't even weed yeah
he's like i'm so [__] high
shatters over and compensating yeah
press
release
guy with a small dick obviously calm
down dude
yeah joffrey dude where is he now
oh who knows man he knows he won't
return any of my texts i've tried to
reach out to him all right we'll pray my
first weekend up at uh i went to
university of minnesota actually uh my
first [__] my first weekend there uh we
were at a bus stop waiting go back to
the saint paul campus and a homeless guy
was talking to us and we were all wasted
and [__] and he sold us shrooms and i
had buddies come up the next weekend and
we sat there and we ate them and the guy
just sold us like portabellas or
something i don't know for 70 bucks 70
bucks for a quad i thought i had the
best deal ever and my friends who drove
up were pissed oh dude that's how that's
how [__] went down yeah but growing up
people would always scam me with fake
[__] it was we would scam the [__] i
dealt drugs for a little while oh yeah
dude
yeah i dealt drugs for 40 minutes for
when i [__] got so i couldn't handle
the pressure wrong [__] called the
cops on myself dude i did one deal and
then i got in trouble with some kid's
mom and then that was
like dude you lived on the edge bro i
can't believe you shared that
holy [__] dude there's going to be cops
on the way over here right now
dude where would you get this dude out
did he just get out of the jail holy
[__] yeah i did i think it's coming
hard corey yeah he just uh they just he
just closed down a cheesecake factory
lunch shift yeah this guy's a real
artist dude this guy's [__] dealing
dude are you a drummer at chuck e cheese
holy [__] damn dude i know man you seem
like a guy that's had a really uh he
actually he just worked a double at the
disney store earlier so he's holy [__]
did you get 86 from a juice bar
holy [__] you can't go back to jamba
juice bro a lot bro that guy used to
work uh he got he used to work at one of
those uh build-a-bears i got trouble for
stuff and i'm too fat oh dude this
dude's on the edge dude
holy [__] holy [__] a roni bro oh my god
are you a farmer a pottery barn dude
just [__] throwing
[__] hay out of your [__] pubes
wow man [__] yeah you've been using
heavy glaze over to color me mine bro or
what's been going on back off the kiln
you little twink dude get the [__] out
of here man you'll give out any size of
lady footlocker dude
so i don't even know what that means
that guy wears a size four [__]
women's shoe bro
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you